how did Nicola catch Bieber's eyes let's  break it down just who is Nicola Peltz  while she comes from a very rich New  York family her father Nelson Peltz is a  mega businessman and worth an estimated  one point nine billion dollars thanks to  riches from Snapple Wendy's and Heinz  Nicola originally wanted to be a hockey  player bonus but at age eleven she  caught the acting bug and by 13 she was  starring in Miley Cyrus's 7 things music  video two years later she would break  out in The Last Airbender at 18 Nicola  nabbed a role on Bates Motel and then  cast the eye of Michael Bay starring  alongside Mark Wahlberg in transformers  age of extinction now 21 Nicola has been  named one of Marie Claire's fresh faces  up 2016 and starred in save Malik's  music video it's you